I'm Christopher Hine. Uh last video we
talked about uh the Tino Henko and the
Roku Tino Henko and and kind of what
that is. And I said that I'm taking
things in a new direction. Um and kind
of getting away from that a little bit.
It's not to say that I'm ever going to
stop using that because they're clever
little ways to explain a way you move to
a position, but overall I think they end
up being more confusing uh for like
beginning middling students than they
need to be. So So I'm changing it. So,
I'm going to talk right now about the
way I change it. And I'm going to talk
about positions and what positions are
and how positions really dictate the
movement you need to make. And the
movement you need to make from one
position to another position is the tino
hinko, right? So, that little brief
second is what it is, but it's simpler
to talk about them than I've talked
about it in the past. So, I'm gonna get
Josh and Maya out here. We're going to
go to work. Josh, Maya,
is we're on long jog right now. Long
jog.
All right. Okay. So, so let's talk about
position uh and how I'm kind of talking
about stuff. Um the term tino is still
absolutely necessary. And to me, Tino
Henko is describing the moment that I
change from one position to another
position and the stuff that's kind of
included in that. But I've kind of
stopped hitting that so hard in lots of
ways because really what's important is
you need to understand the position,
what a better position is than the one
you're in and how to get there. And that
is all of course included in tino just
looking at it in a slightly different
way. Okay, so we've talked about this
before. If it's just me and Josh, right?
So we're just looking at me and Josh
right now. You have muhani that's
without a hanmi. You have hanmi. This
hanmi because my left leg is closest to
Josh's left leg. So those match is I
hani. If I got offline slightly like
this, this would be gaku hani because my
right leg is closest to Josh's left leg.
So in that way we're opposite and that's
gaku, right? So if I came back like
that, then that would be gaku. If I came
off like this, this would be I. But
these are both just hani. And we're
having our bodies up like halfing our
bodies up. Okay. Then we have hitoi,
which is a side by side position. It
means in line in Japanese. So we're in
line like this. And that could be done a
few different ways, right? So we could
be I which is facing the same direction.
We could be choku, which is at a 90°
angle. Or we could be yaku, which is
opposite. Right? Okay. Then we have
eini. And that is this position. And I
think of this as a transitory position
that you're not going to keep for very
long. He's going to be trying to turn
around. So that's why this isn't the
cooho or position. It is the edimi
position because I'm constantly working
to get this. When I'm back here, I'm
either going to be I facing the same
direction as Josh. Choku 90° to Josh or
Gyaku opposite of Josh. Right? So we've
talked about those before and that's the
way I kind of want to start pushing
people to think. Now, you also have to
understand that we have positions for
multiple attackers as well. Okay? So,
actually, I'm gonna have you guys just
stand shoulder-to-shoulder facing the
camera because I think it'll be easier
for the camera to kind of figure out
when I do this. Okay? If we're in this
kind of situation, this is analogous to
aito and me, right? So, we're a side by
side. Okay? And I would try to push to
get behind these guys, right? So, I'd
try to get to Edimi. So, if we look at
them like one, right, as one group, then
we would have Muhani on dead center in
the two of them. And then if I start to
get off to the side, we would have
hanmi. If I get to this line, we have
hitomi. And if I get behind them, we
would have edimi. Right now, really
transitory for the edimi because there's
two of them. I'm almost never going to
be in this situation very long because
one of them is going to turn around real
quick and and we're going to break that.
Okay? So, we can look at it that way.
But then I also have names just
specifically for the formations, like
how we look together. And this is really
how you should start working if you're
working a a multiple attack or dangerous
situation because by understanding these
uh formations, you'll always be able to
know what the next best position is,
right? And of course, this we could
compound this with the previous
examples, right? So, if these two are
side by side and I'm in the middle of
them, okay, like this, this is called a
V formation because they shoot off of me
to my sides like this. This is not a
very good position, but absolutely still
not the worst position because the worst
position would be me being in the
middle. Right? So now why this position
is so bad is if I'm dealing with Maya, I
can't deal with Josh. And I turn around
to deal with Josh, suddenly I can't deal
with Maya. So they can always attack me
from my rear side, which is really bad
for me. Even if I was kind of like this,
I can only kind of half deal with one,
half deal with the other. This would be
my best hope from this terrible
position, but um it's not a good one,
right? And we call this a trap
formation. And the name for that comes
from if I'm back here in a V formation,
turn around for me. Okay. If I'm back
here in a V formation, it might be
enticing sometimes to think I can go
through the middle. But you don't
realize how close together these two
really are. Right? So if they just stick
out their arms right now, there is no
gap there at all. I cannot get through
at all. Right? And all it takes is
either one of them to raise an arm and I
can't get it. Even if they're slightly
wider. Okay, that's significantly wider.
Go ahead and raise your arms. Notice
we're still not in Hanmi. So look, even
though this they're pretty far apart
now, let's have them go out to where
Hani is. So now out here in Maai, when
we're in Maai, look at how big the gap
is. The gap's enormous, right? So that's
where you would have to be normally in
ID to make a safe play uh for Hani,
right? So I'd want to be in a Hani
situation. They have to be that wide.
Look how wide that is. Right? Now, if
they are wider than that, it's not
really a trap formation anymore, right?
So, if they're significantly wider,
you're just dealing with one person. The
other person's too far away to worry
about, right? But up until then, it's a
trap formation, right? So, come back in
for me. So, they come in here. This this
is bad for me, right? So, I'm probably
not going to get through that. Okay? But
this position is still better than the
position of uh a trap formation, right?
So, be in a trap. So, right here, I'm in
a V. All right? Now, if I manage to come
off to the side, we call this a stagger.
So if they turn towards me a little bit,
we have a stagger formation now. Now a
stagger formation is much better because
deal with them one at a time. They're
not both coming up at me. Now if I was
back here in the V formation, they come
at me at the same time, which means I'm
still having to deal with them at once,
right? So I don't have a time advantage
because they still come to me at the
same time. But when I get over here,
I've messed things up for them a little
bit. Josh is going to get to me before
Maya, and that's really, really good. So
I want to start staggering them. Now, a
better position yet would be to come
here and put them perfectly in line with
each other. And now that they're
perfectly in line with each other, Josh
is always blocking Maya's move. Maya's
always got to come around Josh or hit
Josh first or whatever. So, this is way
better for me because Josh is in the way
of Maya. Okay. Now, understand the best
position, which is this position, an eye
formation in a two attacker formation,
is still the worst position in a
multiple attacker situation. So look,
I'm still or in a single attacker
position. I'm still one-on-one with
Josh, right? So I'm still in muhani with
Josh, which is no good, right? If I come
out of this muhan me, I get into a
slightly worse position with Maya
because I give her a free reign, right?
So multiple attackers, even if you
understand how to deal with them, is
always worse than one attacker. And that
might sound silly that I said that right
now, but it's it's worth noting that the
best position for multiple attackers is
still the worst position for one
attacker. So you you kind of can't get
around it. Okay. So these are uh the
basic formations we use. So we can talk
about them in a few different ways. To
me, the formations are easier to talk
about when we're looking at multiple
people. Right? Now, of course, what I'd
like to do is get behind those guys. If
I can get behind of them, great. But
it's going to be mega transitory, right?
So using edimei for that really isn't
that great. Although that is what you
would achieve if you break the line,
right? Right? So, if I was dealing with
these guys and we were in a stagger
formation and I could manage to get here
that I would be shooting edei, right?
So, I've achieved edei as long as
they're both that way. But you can see
and they want to do it right now. The
second I get back here, they're both
just going to turn and I'm no longer in
that edi position, right? So, I got into
a stagger position, which was better
than the V formation that I found myself
in in the beginning, but still not
wonderful, right? So using these
multiple attacker formations is a really
good way to start sussing out what you
should do when there are multiple people
attacking you. You're trying to get into
eye positions. That's what you're trying
to do. If you're dealing with one
person, looking at that one person
you're dealing with, then of course you
want to understand how to work the other
positions from there. But confusing them
can be difficult, right? So for example,
if I'm in a good eye formation and I go
and I'm thinking one-on-one attacker and
I say, "Oh, well, I want to get edi.
Now I'm in the best or I'm in the worst
position. Right? So you always have to
be able to juggle the two people and
understand what it is your goal you're
trying to achieve is. It's not static.
It's always dynamic. Right? So that's
how you're looking at it. All right. So
I hope that was less confusing instead
of more confusing. I'll make more
material if you want on it. Um I also
have a few written things out there that
you can look at. I'm Christopher Hines.
Joshua Tehi. This is my Salana McDaniel.
The ghost runs the cameras. Pan off the
[Music]